Transcription: Almudena Torrecilla
Relecteur: Elisabeth Buffard
Et si nous avions toujours raison ?
Cette question va orienter
ce qu’on va échanger aujourd’hui.
Il y a vingt ans, je commençais
une carrière d’enseignant
et je me dirigeais vers
le village où je travaillais.
Après huit heures de train,
arrivé au terminus,
je m’apprêtais à prendre
le bus pour le village.
Arrivé, les bagages posés,
je suis monté pour chercher
le numéro indiqué sur mon ticket.
J’arrive et je trouve un jeune homme,
un adolescent de l’âge de mes élèves,
qui était assis,
qui prenait toute la place
et regardait par la vitre.
Je m’approche de ce jeune homme,
je lui dis : « Bonjour,
s’il vous plaît, monsieur ? »
Il m’ignore, aucune réaction de sa part,
donc je le pousse un peu du genou,
il me regarde, il me fait de la place.
Installé, une fois le stress
de la situation passé,
je me disais, nous avons encore
six heures devant nous.
Pourquoi ne pas entamer la discussion ?
Alors je me tourne vers lui
et je lance la phrase magique.
« Il fait beau aujourd’hui. »
Mais là encore, aucune réaction.
Donc, je me dis,
le monsieur veut être tranquille.
Après une heure de trajet,
nous étions arrêtés le temps d’un café
et le bus reprenait son trajet
et à la sortie, nous avions un accident.
Un véhicule est venu percuter notre bus
juste là où nous étions assis.
Et là, ce jeune homme se tourne vers moi.
Il me prend par la main spontanément
et il me dit : « eh ! »
et il me fait signe de regarder.
Après 20 ans, je ne sais plus
qu’est-ce que je ressentais exactement,
mais je me rappelle d’une chose,
je me rappelle
que je le fixais du regard.
J’avais oublié l’accident,
j’avais oublié la réaction
de tous les passagers.
Je le regardais et je me disais
que je n'avais pas raison.
Il faut dire qu’être professeur
à l’âge de 21 ans,
devant 180 adolescents par jour,
faire le show quatre heures par jour,
faire du théâtre, les amuser,
avait été pour moi un remède
contre le manque de confiance en moi.
Mais ce remède avait un effet indésirable,
c’était celui d’augmenter le sentiment
que j’avais toujours raison.
Et dans cette situation,
j’avais appris qu’en fait, non.
J’avais appris à travers cette situation
à valoriser le silence.
J’avais appris qu’en fait
écouter n’était pas une réaction.
Écouter n’était pas une réaction
suite à quelqu’un qui prend la parole.
Pour moi, le silence précédait l'écoute.
Les cinq heures qui restaient du voyage,
je les avais passées à réfléchir,
à méditer autour de cette situation.
Je me disais comment
aurais-je pu m’excuser
si j’avais été violent
avec cette personne,
si j’avais été agressif envers elle.
Mais cette situation
m’avait appris d’autres leçons.
La leçon que j’avais apprise, c’est que...
le silence...
indiquait une écoute de soi.
J’avais appris qu’il fallait s’écouter,
maîtriser cette voix intérieure
qui vous dit : « vous avez raison. »,
pour bien écouter.
Mais j’avais appris aussi
que l’écoute était en fait un voyage.
Lorsqu’on voyage vers une destination
qu’on ne connaît pas,
pour la première fois,
durant tout le voyage, on est émerveillé,
on accorde de l’importance à tout.
On valorise les détails
et on est attentif jusqu’à destination.
Lorsqu’on voyage vers une destination
qu’on connaît déjà,
peut-être qu’on va dormir
pendant le trajet
ou encore être sur notre téléphone.
On n’accorde plus attention aux détails
et on fait plus attention vraiment
à tout ce qu’on vit durant ce voyage
parce qu’on n’attend pas de surprises.
On n’est pas dans
une logique de découverte.
L’écoute doit être axée sur la découverte.
La découverte de soi
et la découverte de l’image
que l’autre se fait du monde et du sens.
Je voudrais vous proposer un exercice.
Je vais vous demander
de dessiner une histoire.
Je vais vous raconter une histoire
et je vais vous demander
de ne rien écrire.
C’est la première règle à respecter,
n’écrivez rien, juste dessinez.
La deuxième règle, c’est que
si je dis quelque chose d’impossible,
d’improbable ou encore de bizarre
pour vous, vous arrêtez de dessiner.
Donc, l’histoire dit :
j’ai rencontré un ami.
Je lui ai dit:
« J’ai oublié mon portable.
Ce portable était cher,
il pesait deux kilos. »
Bien, je vois qu’il y a
des mains qui se lèvent.
Qu’est-ce qui, dans l’histoire,
vous semble bizarre ou impossible ?
C’est ça, les ordinateurs portables
d’aujourd’hui, lorsqu’ils sont chers,
généralement, ils sont légers.
Parce que oui, on parlait
d’un ordinateur portable.
Si vous avez dessiné
un téléphone portable,
ça veut dire que vous avez le même
numéro de place que j’avais dans ce bus.
Ça voudrait dire que vous avez
revécu la même situation,
que vous êtes assis maintenant
dans le siège où j’étais assis,
que vous êtes étonnés
autant que j’étais étonné.
Cet exercice, en fait,
reflète la communication.
Lorsqu’on communique avec quelqu’un,
on dessine ensemble
cette image de la réalité,
on dessine ensemble cette image du sens.
Mais lorsqu’on décide
que la destination qu’on partage
avec cette personne
est une destination connue,
on arrête de l’écouter et on arrête
de dessiner cette image du monde.
Et c’est ce qui vient de se passer.
Ce qu’il faut savoir,
c’est que pour écouter,
il faut être dans une perspective
de découverte.
Lorsqu’on écoute,
on accueille cette vision du monde.
Si vous voulez changer
le comportement de quelqu’un,
que ce soit dans votre vie quotidienne,
personnelle, ou que ce soit en entreprise,
commencez par faire ce voyage intérieur,
commencez par maîtriser cette voix qui
vous dit que vous avez toujours raison.
Dans mon métier,
je suis toujours fasciné de voir
des équipes travailler sur un même projet,
avec les mêmes idées, la même passion,
être d’accord sur le sens,
mais dire les choses différemment,
les comprendre différemment
et avoir des conflits sur une base
qui était au départ commune.
Donc, pour vous dire
si vous voulez écouter,
soyez attentif à votre voix intérieure,
découvrez ce que l’autre veut dire.
Si vous faites ça,
vous aurez toujours raison.
Merci.